kunst ist ein millionengeschäft dies ist
das teuerste kunstwerk das jemals seinen
besitzer gewechselt hat salvador multi
von leonardo da vinci für 382 millionen
euro
stellen wir uns also einmal die
unverkäufliche mona lisa vor das wohl
berühmteste gemälde der welt mit einem
unschätzbaren wert nur dass das gar
nicht die echte mona lisa ist das ist
eine perfekte fälschung eine fälschung
die kein sterblicher vom original
unterscheiden kann es könnte genauso gut
ein atom getreu aktionen seien das
original und der fake sind objektiv
gesehen identisch aber trotzdem nicht
gleich viel wert es ist sogar ziemlich
leicht herauszufinden welches davon dass
echte ist man stellt sich davor wirft
einen genauen blick drauf dreht sich
einmal oben und stellt fest ja ich bin
im louvre in frankreich oder eben nicht
fall geschlossen das eine ist
unschätzbar wertvoll und das hirn will
mich dass gerade erklärt habe wird mir
jeder recht geben aber dennoch fällt es
einigen inklusive mir selbst schwer zu
glauben dass am 11 märz 2021 jesusbild
eine einfache jpeg datei sein besitzer
für 69,3 millionen dollar gewechselt
obwohl jeder mit seinem pc einfach eine
identische kopie erstellen kann und ich
habe es ja auch einfach runter geladen
warte was mfps wie das hier sind der
neuste heiße kryptisch aus dem netz das
hier sieht wenn man sie wenigstens noch
eine harte arbeit aus aber keine angst
ein totes niemals gift verkauft für
690.000 dollar dieses pixel bild das
aussieht als hätte es ein zehnjähriger
in paint gemacht verkauft für 7,6
millionen dollar
und da stellt sich die frage was ist das
findet und aber noch viel wichtiger kann
ich auch einfach irgendwas empfängt
erstellen und das 400.000 euro verkaufen
oder gibt es da einen haken diese woche
finde ich genau das heraus und erstellen
eigene mfps und zwar zuerst ganz geheim
ohne reich weiter mit
rettet und diskos und danach zum
vergleich öffentlich mit hilfe meiner
reichweite dieses video wird unterstützt
von will noch bevor ich recherchiere wie
das eigentlich funktioniert und warum
genau das tape act als am 11 märz mit 69
millionen dollar als nft über den tisch
gegen so viel besser ist als die gleiche
datei die ich kostenlos von google
bilder geladen habe erstelle ich wie
sich das gehört einfach mal selbst ein
pixel art figuren die man zu einer art
kollektion zusammenschnüren kann scheint
mir besonders gut ankommen und ich pixel
artikel finde wie man vielleicht an
meiner app downloads gelb erkennen kann
mache ich so was einfach mal auch nur
nicht ganz so billig und ein hübsch wie
diese coupons wovon der ersteller an
einem einzelnen mehr verdient hat als
mehr kritisch letzten 16 jahre als
bundeskanzlerin sondern etwas
aufwendiger und etwas möglich also dass
ich nach vier stunden ja tatsächlich
diesen süßen kleinen retro fuchs fertig
habe der mir einmal fiona fox peter
penguin und einfach mal dass karl-heinz
koala mir ist einfach keinen schöneren
namen mit k eingefallen aha
er ist mein liebling und jetzt die frage
wie schwer ist es daraus aus tiefen
süßen kleinen dinge hier geld zu
verdienen
vielleicht ist es daraus jetzt ein nfc
zu zaubern ich bin gespannt jetzt einmal
der karl heinz kahler reingezogen
jackpot unzählig markant sofortkauf ich
kann so einem ding jetzt nicht in den
wert zu sprechen dass ich meinen das
sollen die leute selber entscheiden was
sie bezahlen wollen wenn überhaupt bevor
ich irgendwas jetzt machen muss ich
erstmal meine wallet connecten kein
baseball das funktioniert 6 s world ist
links ist die collection ob ich hatte
guten namen pixel so einfach das ist
ketsch ii was ist denn truppen nehmen
was für simple was das ding zu erstellen
kostet 1700 dollar
ich werde jetzt gleich erstmal
herausfinden was ich hier überhaupt
mache bevor ich jetzt gleich knapp 2.000
dollar dafür ausgeben ist das
wahrscheinlich keine schlechte idee aber
ich denke diese stelle bietet sich ganz
gut an für unseren heutigen sponsor denn
wie ihr seht ist das alles mit
verschiedenen brokern und wolle jetzt
immer noch etwas kompliziert wenn ihr
selbst im bitkom premium und co
investieren wollte ist die leichteste
methode dafür wo die neue kräfte
funktion von vivid wir wird hat uns
bereits letztes jahr unterstützt
weswegen ich mich freuen auch dieses
feature vorstellen zu können jetzt könnt
ihr auch noch direkt über die app in
aktien etfs und sogar trifft währungen
investieren
bei aktien ist es cool dass hierbei wird
auch in teil aktien investieren kann so
eine amazon aktie steht da zum beispiel
bei über zweieinhalbtausend euro wenn
ihr aber zum beispiel nur mit einem cent
in amazon investieren möchtet könnt ihr
das hier mit einem klick machen und das
sogar gebührenfrei das gleiche gilt
natürlich auch für crypto ohne gebühren
und mit einem klick
zehn der größten und beliebtesten
konzept der aktuell zur auswahl zum
beispiel bitcoin interim und leid freuen
das ganze geht rund um die ohren ihr
müsst dafür nicht mehr haus verlassen
will wird ist eine topmoderne mobile
banking app mit der man ganz normal geld
überweisen mit dieser schicken mit
zahlungen tätigen und den sogenannten
forbes sein geld organisieren kann
also wenn er das als auch interessiert
ladet euch die banken wie wird man hier
unter und profitiert von dieser
exklusiven finanziellen vorteil weiter
mit unserer mission kann man
die fts einfach geld verdienen bevor ich
nämlich jetzt für irgendwas ausgebe von
dem ich keine ahnung habe erklären wir
jetzt mal die nft es eigentlich
funktionieren das nf steht für nonnen
von jebel also nicht austauschbar aber
was heißt das
naja diese ein euro münze ist genauso
viel wert wie diese oder diese anderen
hier sie ist also austauschbar und das
ist das geniale an geld und deswegen
funktioniert es zu viel geld ist
austauschbar in dem sinne dass man 5 1
euro münzen einfach mit einem
fünf-euro-schein austauschen kann der
denselben wert
aber es ist auch austauschbar in dem
sinne dass wenn dir einen 100 euro
schein gestohlen wird dir deine
diebstahlversicherung einfach einen
anderen als ersatz gibt und du dann
glücklich bist wenn die allerdings die
von seinem großvater vermachte uhr
geschaut für die er in den 60er jahren
sein erstes gehalt geopfert hat und von
dem er sein letzter wille war dass du
sie für ihn weiter tragen erst dann wird
sie nur ein schwacher trost sein einfach
irgendeine andere baugleiche ruhe als
entschädigung zu bekommen
diese uhr hat für dich eine nicht
austauschbaren wert weil es nur eine
gibt also ist sie nun von jebel genauso
wie dieser handschuh von michael jackson
weil er michael jackson getragen wurde
oder diese original mona lisa weil sie
die einzige ist die wirklich vor 100
moment mal vor 500 jahren wo vor 500
jahren von leonardo da vinci gemalt
wurde
wir hatten also gekehrt wo für das ns in
nfc steht aber was ist ein pc für token
was wörtlich übersetzt heißt das
wertmarke klassische wertmarken sind zum
beispiel casino chips oder pfandmarken
von festivals ohne pfand marke ist zum
beispiel der beweis dafür dass man der
rechtmäßige anspruch habe für die ein
euro ist dies als pfand auf zum beispiel
ein bierglas gibt sonst könnt ihr einem
festival einfach irgend jemand rumlaufen
sich alle möglichen biergläser
einsammeln um sich dann das ganze fand
einzuheimsen wo kann man denn da hin
das geht hier nur mit dieser marke sie
ist also eine art urkunde aber eben eine
austauschbare es wird hier nicht
unterschieden welche einzelne marke oder
welches einzelnen glas ich habe dies
also von jebel faya bedrucken sind auch
urkunden die mich zum beispiel zum
rechtmäßigen besitzer von wir sind pixel
bild hier machen nur dass diese urkunden
digital und durch einen kryptischen code
einzigartig sind diese eigenschaften
beziehungsweise die prägung des mft es
hat aber ihren preis und wie das bei
cryptic üblich ist ist die
rechenpower für die man bezahlen muss
ich habe allerdings nun eine plattform
gefunden über der diese prägung und
damit die kosten erst geschehen wenn man
einen festen käufer hat wodurch ich im
voraus immerhin nur 330 dollar zahlen
muss um mich zu verifizieren und nichts
1700 dollar
diese 330 dollar gingen übrigens nicht
an die plattform diese gebühr deckt so
weit ich weiß nur die kosten für die
benötigte rechenpower
ich ziehe also per drag drop man bild in
dieses fenster gebe meinem kunstwerk
einen namen und eine beschreibung und
los geht's da wir unsere drei werke wie
die ganzen coolen andere leute
versteigern wollen stelle ich keinen
direkten verkauf sondern eine auktion
ein mit einer deadline in drei tagen und
fertig jetzt heißt abwarten die auktion
ist jetzt gestartet und jeder kann nun
ein gebot abgeben wie bei ihm bei für
eines der red shops unter jeweils
höchstbietende mit daneben der neue
eigentümer also wenn überhaupt jemand
bietet denn die plattform scheint mir
jetzt nicht wirklich werbung für meine
kunst zu machen also muss ich das selbst
in die hand nehmen und zwar wie gesagt
zum test erst mal ganz ohne reichweite
mit mitteln die jeder zur verfügung hat
mit einem wasserzeichen versehen das
über einen link auf meine mfps führt
poste ich in einem pixel ausfuhr um
meine bilder und hoffe darauf dass sie
jemanden in einem nfc forum werde ich
auf eine disc gruppe mit hunderten nft
käufern und verkäufern aufmerksam in der
ich sogar direkt werbung für meine werke
machen
wenige tage später habe ich zum beispiel
auf diesem redet post sogar elf uploads
und wahrscheinlich noch deutlich mehr
ansicht gekauft oder auch nur geboten
hat aber niemand die mfps hatten aber
alle immer zwischen fünf und fünfzehn
klicks das heißt unsere werbung hat
wenigstens ein bisschen ausgebracht
trotzdem an das glaube ich ganz gut
gezeigt dass nfc es vor allem was denn
für menschen die im internet schon eine
kleine fanbase an die sich bereits für
ihre kunden präsent wie zb dieser bibel
der durch die nft infizierung von diesen
bildern hier zum multimillionär geworden
dass wir bereits am anfang erwähnt
werden wir das jetzt auch testen was
passiert wenn ich das ganze jetzt noch
mal machen aber diesmal öffentlich die
kollektion heißt vetropack die auktion
statt also genau jetzt über den link in
der video beschreibung das ganze kripo
kalkar relativ wie co2 verursacht wenn
ich dafür höchstpersönlich die co2
kompensation also bäume pflanzen oder
sowas
es hat gerade einfach vollgas ins bett
gehen und schauen noch mal nach und hat
einfach alle drei hunden
dollar geboten 0,1 terium oder mehrere
geboten ist hat erst einmal für drei
euro 48 geboten an einer für 365 und
dann eine einfache für 350 direkten des
kasse ist dank diesem erster bieter der
der wert der ehrenmann
er war der erste der geboten hat da hat
das glaube ich ein bisschen ins rollen
gebracht also das ist bisher schon mega
erfolg damit ist das ganze ding was ich
jetzt gemacht habe schon mal halbwegs
profitabel
also ok eigentlich ist es hier um
ehrlich zu sein genau die menschen die
ich bisher schon da reingesteckt haben
für die ganzen transaktionen und so
weiter und so fort aber ich habe auch
noch andere fts und vielleicht lauert da
ja auch noch was vielleicht ist ja das
nicht das einzige was geboten wurde
und action mein gott was es wurden
überall 350 dollar geboten bei jedem
auch hier hatte der wert wieder zuerst
geboten dann allerdings der 15 96 22
der wahrscheinlich auch den sich dann
gönnen will wählt hier der bär als
suntech pirat auf jeden fall der wert
alter der ehrenmann 1596 22 mit 1000
dollar insgesamt kann man sparen ins
bett gehen ich weiß nicht ob der morgen
immer noch auf die geisteskranken kommt
dazu gebeten weil das ist schon kranker
sprung von 3 eur 60 hier auf 350 euro
mal schauen die eigentlich danach wir
waren bei 0,1 terium überall gute der
wert waren der erste der über angebote
abgeliefert hat und 2000 eine terium hat
er 15 9
er dachte sich 0,1 terium ja 350 euro
ich will das ding wo ich bin ich dachte
okay da mehr wird es nicht mehr wird das
überhaupt nicht das war irgendwie cooler
aber der wäre es ja sehr gut
da dachte sich ich habe nicht nur 0 001
terium ich habe auch ein paar 1,105 et
um hatte noch mal um 20 euro geboten
aber ja der 159
er hat es überhaupt nicht gefallen
lassen
und alba 500 dollar geboten und jetzt
muss auch jetzt was auch das wiederum
hat denn der bald auch nicht gefallen
jetzt hat der wird sich gedacht okay
wenn ich schon nicht meinen guten peter
pinguine kriegt den ich ein gebäude hat
er jetzt die hintertür genommen und dann
hatte einfach bei dem guten karl heinz
kahler wurde 159 auch freaks bieten
erwarte ihn nochmal über boden mit 1,1
herzlich lacht okay dann nehme ich mir
jetzt den endlich den karl heinz kahler
aber 159 hat es nicht auf sich sitzen
lassen wo die rauchfrei dollar
reingehauen
haha ja also die beiden haben richtig
geil und ich bin gespannt also warum
kommt ja noch drei stunden 40 minuten
über es ist einfach tradition das ende
nähert sich in weniger als zwei stunden
steht fest wie hoch geboten wird und ob
sich der wert zurück an die spitze
kämpft oder vielleicht noch den fuchs
ersteigern will aber scheinbar nicht
okay noch zwei minuten einfach ich bin
gespannt ob jetzt noch etwas passiert
dann letzten zwischenstand ist auch
nichts passiert jetzt kann allerdings
noch alles passieren wir haben noch neun
acht sieben sechs fünf vier drei zwei
eins und es durch genauso kann ja dann
quasi reingehen und die einzelnen
angebote akzeptieren dass man jetzt
manche akzeptiert weil sie diesen kuala
für 500 dollar also ein bisschen
bisschen wie sms kostet jetzt noch
einmal 90 dollar zusätzlich denn jetzt
erst genau in diesem moment wird das lft
überhaupt erstellt das war davor nur
virtuell das wetter kader
wir haben jetzt aber auch hier den guten
pinguin wir auch ein angebot haben sind
wir dran waren ebenfalls 1,5 kg
transactions erzielt also unser karl
heinz kurras der hatten besitzer
gewechselt der gehört jetzt quasi im
blut mit pinguin ist auch durch hat auch
ein besitzer gewechselt
und hier hat tatsächlich beim fuchs
jetzt tatsächlich noch last second der
der wert zugeschlagen hatten der das
gemacht er hat einfach eine minute vor
20 uhr noch über den anderen überboten
ist dadurch jetzt quasi der
höchstbietende hab ich gönne es ihm
augen weil das der der wird noch mal was
aus sich gegönnt hat und es ist durch
und sieht man hier unter activity dass
ich quasi
drei stück verkauft hab zwei davon an
den 159 60 21 davon an denen ich bin
jetzt mal gespannt wie viel von den
profit nach den extrem hohen gebühren
überhaupt noch über bleibt wir rechnen
mal alles zusammen am anfang des
experiments muss ich mich erstmal eine
terium kaufen für knapp 2000 euro da bin
ich was haben diese ganze gebühren zu
bezahlen die gebühren für diesen kauf
waren ungefähr 43 dollar dann für die
übertragung in meine rolle waren schon
mal 20 dollar für die validierung bei
der nfc plattform waren es insgesamt
ungefähr 340 dollar
muss ich das zweimal ich weiß nicht
warum und für die prägung der einzelnen
nft es waren sie jeweils ungefähr 90
dollar haben wir dann insgesamt immer
noch einen gewinn von 787 dollar nicht
so ganz gewonnen hat bei der sache hier
die umwelt weil das ganze crypto
gewöhnten ziemlich hohem stromverbrauch
für alles was ich heute gemacht habe
insgesamt 560 kw das ist ungefähr so
viel wie ich in zwei monaten verbraucht
ich berufe mich übrigens hier auf das
ergebnis der recherche von pulse
reportage die haben nämlich einen tag
nachdem ich meine mfps erstellt habe
auch eine doku dazu veröffentlichten co2
umgerechnet sind wir dann bei 270
kilogramm ich hatte von anfang an gesagt
dass ich das co2 kompensieren werde das
heißt zum beispiel man pflanzt einfach
irgendwo bäume wohl noch keine sind
damit die bäume daneben co2 aus der luft
binden können bei dem plattform die ich
dafür gefunden habt kostet als alles
zwischen sechs und 20 euro allerdings
habe ich unter einem kommentar von euch
geschrieben bekommt das ist doch cool
dass bei well done es international zu
machen
da kann man sich nämlich ein paar
regenwald boden kaufen der dann eben
nicht abgeholzt oder verbrannt wird
wodurch das co2 in die luft geht und
natürlich vor allem damit die tiere da
nicht vertrieben werden und ich fans
eigentlich ziemlich cool weil ich hatte
ursprünglich deutlich mehr als diese
drei mfps geplant unter anderem nämlich
dieses faultier hier und wer natürlich
ultra geil wenn diese ganzen tiere die
wir hier so gut finden auch irgendwann
noch ein platz zum leben haben deswegen
habe ich jetzt nicht die 620 euro
sondern den gesamten erlös ungefähr
umgerechnet 660 dollar in regenwald land
beziehungsweise im faultier land wie sie
das nennen in peru investiert haben
damit also 880 quadratmeter regenwald
vor dem abholzen geschützt was doch
eigentlich ganz gute sache ist und ja
ich habe hier übrigens als notizen hier
in dem brief vom ans licht
für das notiz material trübte und co2
oder umweltschutz ist ein kompliziertes
thema ich denke ich werde etwas habe ich
noch ein paar weiteren red chopins macht
den link zu denken ja wie wird die
dieses video heute unterstützt hat
findet ihr natürlich wegbeschreibungen
dann würde ich sagen aber nicht ganz
gehalten dass man jetzt wieder macht's
gut
[Musik]